Even if producers at the History Channel knew
they'd struck gold when they cast the stars
of Mountain Men, they couldn't have predicted
just how rich the vein they'd hit.
Here are just a few tidbits of trivia that
never made it to television screens, all about
the toughest guys in the world.
Eustace Conway's School Beef
Inspired by Henry David Thoreau, Eustace Conway
ran his North Carolina-based nature school
on his own property for over two decades without
incident.
But in February 2012, county officials claimed
they discovered some safety violations and
shut it all down.
"The county government has issued Eustace
a cease and desist order, telling him to shut
down his nature school, saying his buildings
don't meet code."
Conway and his staff were shocked at the county's
sudden crackdown, since he said that the county's
previous inspections hadn't ever found any
problems:
"We've never had anybody hurt by one of the
buildings, we've never had any health issue
here, and so like after 26 years that's a
pretty strong statement."
He and his staff didn't see how they could
comply with the new demands:
"If we complied to everything that the county
is requesting, we would cease to exist as
we are.
It's just not an option."
Conway thought he'd been wronged, and took
his fight to the courts.
Fortunately, the state stepped in and passed
a law providing an exemption for his school
in 2013.
Not Very Neighborly
About ten months into Conway's dispute with
the county, he got into a fight with his neighbor,
Margaret A. Palms.
She told The High Country Press that they
were once good friends, until Conway disputed
the property line they'd shared for years.
The argument reached a head in December 2012.
Palms told the Press:
"He went and tied our gate shut, so we couldn’t
get out and he put posters all over our gates,
mailboxes, fences.
Then he put big wooden barriers, so we couldn’t
get out.
He just kind of went nuts."
But Conway got another good break.
In May of the following year, The High Country
Press reported that the charges had been dismissed.
Tom Oar's One-Day Audition
People who live off the land are unfairly
stereotyped as being a little crazy.
But, indeed, some folks who decide to go off
the grid are gifted with more of that special
something that makes for great reality TV.
Take Tom Oar, for example: on the recommendation
of Oar's neighbor, Mountain Men followed him
around for a day before they decided he had
to be on television.
Of course, they probably didn't take into
account some of the things that they might
have to endure, like follow him on a three-day
hunting expedition whilst carrying 25 pounds
of camera equipment.
If anyone was crazy in this situation, it
might have been the crew.
Oar's Business Boom
Unlike some reality-television personalities,
Tom Oar has adjusted pretty well to his newfound
fame.
Selling moccasins, custom knives, and other
wilderness goodies, Mountain Men’s Oar cleans
up, as viewers have started clamoring for
his goods.
If you're interested in buying some of it,
however, we have bad news: Oar doesn't have
an internet presence, which means you have
to get your butt to Yaak, Montana, if you
want some genuine merchandise.
If he's not sold out, that is.
Charlie Tucker's House Was A Local Attraction
Before Mountain Men started, Charlie Tucker
was already a local celebrity in North Maine
woods.
Not only did everyone in town know about the
guy who built a cabin with his own hands,
his house was also one of two stops on a day-long
tour.
After taking the tour themselves, producers
saw in Tucker a "willpower and stubbornness"
that told them he had to be on their show.
Protector Of The People
Years before he gained fame on Mountain Men,
Rich Lewis was already hailed as a hero in
Montana for his reputation for mountain-lion
fighting.
In 2007, a mountain lion ran amok in Twin
Bridges, Montana, killing two dogs.
Had it been left alone, there's no telling
what it would have done next; fortunately,
the Department of Fish, Wildlife, and Parks
reached an agreement with Lewis and set him
loose on the cougar.
He took it out before it could harm any other
animals—or worse, someone's child.
Rich Lewis's Dog Delivery
In season four of Mountain Men, Lewis lost
his best friend, his dog Brandy.
Bill Lane, Dan Turner, and Lucas Sims, all
fans of the show, knew they needed to do something,
so they brought him a new canine companion.
To make this heartfelt gesture, the trio journeyed
1,700 miles to Lewis' off-the-grid homestead.
It's Good For Local Business
When the History Channel decided to send camera
crews to follow Lewis and Oar through remote
areas of Montana, they probably didn't anticipate
the good it would do.
Rather than send their own crews out into
the wild, producers hired the local Warm Springs
Productions crew to film the wilderness buffs.
By 2013, the company employed roughly 70 people
and needed to move into a larger facility.
In addition, Mountain Men led to other gigs,
like filming for the Travel Channel's Making
Monsters.
Marty Meierotto: Life Saver
Because of the public's fascination with these
rugged outdoorsmen, newspapers and magazines
have taken it upon themselves to find out
more about them.
This isn't always a good idea.
Field & Stream magazine sent Bill Heavey to
spend some time with Marty Meierotto.
As the writer followed Meierotto around during
an Alaskan winter for three days, he quickly
discovered he was out of his element.
At one point, Heavey tried to make it back
to Marty's cabin on his own, and got lost.
Luckily, Meierotto knew what he was doing,
and was able to save the reporter from becoming
a popsicle.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
Mountain Men fact surprised you the most...